our next speaker is
he is a phd at uc berkeley and a swiss
research fellow in the probability
program
all right thanks prasad hopefully you
can hear me
awesome um so in case you just one
picture wasn't enough there's another
picture on the slide
um so i'll be joining georgia tech next
year
and my phd at berkeley was among other
things on
adaptation automatic adaptation to
structure in high dimensional estimation
problems
so today what i'll tell you a little bit
about is what that perspective has to
bring to
reinforcement learning um and
this is important at a high level both
in theory and practice because lots of
the worst case theory we have in
reinforcement learning
can often be extremely pessimistic and
secondly
some notion of the intrinsic difficulty
of problems is helpful
also in algorithm development because
multiple algorithms may be optimal in
the worst case
and then you may see differences as you
you know zoom in
um so this is based on joint work with a
variety of wonderful collaborators at
berkeley
next slide um so the particular thing
that i want to tell you about today is
policy evaluation which is this
extremely simple problem of solving a
linear system
um it's uh evaluating what's called the
value function of a markov reward
process so the markov reward process is
given by some tuple pnr a transition
matrix
and a reward function and you want to
find the value function which is given
by the solution to that equation in the
middle
so what we'll operate in today's model
called the simulator or the generative
model where you just get iad samples
from this
pair and you have to evaluate the value
function next slide
so there are variety of concrete
algorithms you might think of that that
work with these samples
um i don't expect you to read the math
here but many of them are very very
natural right from what's called the
plug-in estimator in statistics
um to others based on stochastic
approximation
um so typically you don't just do this
in the ambient space next slide um you
do this
in um what's called the function
approximation setting where you also
have some subspace typically denoted
there by
the phi quantity and you run exactly the
same algorithms with projections onto
these subspaces so these go with a
variety of names
um in the temporal difference learning
family what might you like
next slide um you might like estimates
right that satisfy a guarantee like in
the bottom so this is what would be
called an oracle inequality in
statistics
you want some guarantee on the
approximation error how far you are from
the best approximation within the
subspace
up to some additive statistical error
capturing noise in the problem and
that's going to
guide our development today in this
instance dependent
fashion so in the next 30 seconds let me
tell you a little bit about each of
those starting with the statistical
error
epsilon n next slide um so here i'm
going to use
something to parameterize instances the
details are unimportant
except to see that i can actually vary
the difficulty of the problem here on
the x-axis by simply varying the
discount factor gamma
next slide and what you'll see is if you
plot
the behavior of many of the algorithms
that i talked about on the previous
slide you actually see a distinct
difference all of these algorithms are
worst case optimal in a certain sense
but when you plot it with the difficulty
of the problem in particular this
effective horizon
you see a separation the temporal
difference learning algorithms are
distinctly sub-optimal
whereas the plug-in algorithm is in fact
optimal as compared to a lower bound
which is information
theoretic the stochastic approximation
algorithms can also be improved with a
variance reduction device to make them
optimal next slide this brings us to the
approximation error
the factor that sits outside the minimum
possible error
and classical results have known that
you can upper bound this approximation
error by something that depends on the
discount factor it grows as the discount
factor goes to one
what we show next slide um is that the
story is significantly more nuanced
um as you look at the ambient dimension
of the problem what you can show is an
instance dependent characterization now
that provides both upper and lower
bounds showing that these algorithms are
optimal in certain regimes but
sub-optimal in others
next slide and this should conclude
although i said this for a very specific
setting there are consequences for more
broad settings in reinforcement learning
as well
thank you